foreign
[Music]
my name is Percy Jackson am I a troubled
kid yeah you could say that bad grades
bullies
all the normal stuff and then there's
some stuff that's maybe not so normal
[Music]
you saw something
something that no one else could see
[Music]
the stories that I have told you about
Greek gods and half-bloods they are real
Ms Jackson things have changed since
it's all developing a lot faster than we
anticipated over why is your Apple go in
your pants
so the important thing is not to panic
Percy Jackson
we've been expecting you
the master
has been stolen
that is your quest
[Music]
remember what I taught you
you're gonna need to be brave now
[Music]
foreign